[موسيقى]
بدنا نستخدم الكود اللي معنا شوي وبدي
ابلش
بالعلامه الكامله ابدا مو سر النجاح
هلا معانا كارت خضره بدنا نرفعها اذا في
اليوم من الايام درسنا لماده كتير منيح بس
وقت ما اجى وقت تسليم العلامات ما جبنا
علامه كامله
كثير منيح
ويحس حاله فاهمها كثير منيح وقادر يطبقها
اليوم بالميه بس وقت تسليم العلامات برضو
ما جاب علامه كامله
مين فينا بيزعل لما ما يجيب العلامه
الكامله
هلا بدي احكي لكم قصتي مع العلامه الكامله
بدي ارجع بالماضي شوي وتحديدا لاول يوم
الي بالمدرسه وانا عم بشوف المديره عم
بتكرم الاوائل وبتقول لازم تكونوا زي هذول
صار في صوت جواتي والغيره لعبه دول وقلت
انا لازم اكون زي هذول وفعلا اللي صار كل
سنه كنت اوقف على المنصه وينحك عني لازم
تكون زيها خلصت المدرسه والكل بيعرف اني
متفوقه ودخلت الجامعه وكان هدفي خلال
الجامعه انه دائما اسمي على لوحه الشرف
بكل فصل
وكان حلمي انه اطلع الاولى على الجامعه
ما بتذكر اني بيوم فكرت شو راح اعمل بعد
ما اتخرج حتى لما كانوا يعمل ورشه او اذن
او حتى يجيبه ضيف لا يحكي عن سوء العمل
بصراحه
خرجت من الجامعه وطلعت الاولى على الدفعه
وعلى الكليه كمان
وهيك كل الطلاب كان همهم يعملوا السيره
ذاتيه حتى يدوروا على فرص عمل بالوقت اللي
انا ما عملت وحده وكنت متخيله انه تفوقي
ما راح يخليني بحاجه لها
من الدفعه كلهم اشتغلوا حتى الي ما كانوا
يجيبوا علامات كامله
ذكرت شوي طيب ما انا اخذت ماده بالجامعه
بالضبط بتعلمني زي هيك بس برضو جبت فيها
ميه من 100 طب ليه اروح احضر الورشه بس
قلت خليني اروح احضر هالورشه
وكانت هاي اول مره بسمع حقائق ما كنت
بعرفها ما كنت بعرف انه هالورقه الي اسمها
هي اهم ورقه بحياتي وهي ملخص لكل انجازاتي
وهي ملخص لكل انجازاتي واللي بده يقراها
ما رح ياخذ اكثر من سبع ثواني حتى يقرر
يقابلني او ما يختارني
لازم حقيقتنا ونخليها تعبر عن شخصيتنا
لحتى نلاقي الوظيفه اللي بتناسبنا ونبعد
عن الجمل التقليديه والممله ما نعمل كوفي
بيس لسيفيت حدا واقول ما هي كلها وخلاص
ما كنت بعرف انه اهم مكان بدور فيه على
فرص العمل هو ليندا
وهون تذكرت انه بالجامعه لما درست عرفت ما
تتاسس وكيف بيشتغل وقد ايه هو مهم حتى
الاقي فرصه عمل بس اللي ما كنت بعرفه
والاهم انه لازم يكون عندي اكاونت فعال
عليه اشيكه كل يوم والاهم من هيك ابلش
اكون شبكه مهنيه ما كنت بعرف انه هسه فيه
لها اتكيت ويا جماعه
اتذكره لازم تكون حاليا من الاخطاء
الاملائيه واللغويه نبعد عن الالوان
والتنسيق الغير متناسق صفحه واحده صدقوني
بتكفي اذا انا عملت بالطريقه الصح والاهم
انه نتاكد انه رقم التلفون الي عليها صحيح
حتى الشركات يقدروا يتواصلوا معنا
ممكن يتغير حسب الجهه او الوظيفه او حتى
المكان اللي انا عم بقدم له فاذا انا عم
بقدم لانجي كثير مهم اني اكتب عن العمل
التطوعي الي عملته انا كخريجي جديد ما
عندي خبره من هنيه بس صدقوني انه التدريب
الي عملته بالجامعه ممكن يهمني ويساعدني
اني احصل على فرصه عمل يا جماعه تدريب مهم
حتى لو ما كان مدفوع الاجر تذكرت بوقتها
انه كانت التدريب على وقت اختياري بصراحه
ما اخذته وبيني وبينكم لو حدا خبرني انه
70% من الشركات ياللي بيعطوا تدريب للطلاب
بينتهي تدريبهم جنب قصر و80% من هالطلاب
بيقبلوا هالجب اوفر
المهم انا عملتها السي دي وزبطت بروفايلي
على اللينك وضفت المهارات اللي بتناسب
مؤهلاتي قدراتي
وفعلا ما مر يومين الا بيحكي معي واحد من
اكبر البنوك في الاردن بصراحه ملاحظتها
كيفت واخيرا رح اشتغل بالمكان اللي الكل
بيعرفه شركه كبيره ومين ما يسالني وين
اشتغلت رح احكي لهم اسم المكان ويعرفوا
المهم حكوا معي على مقابله وبلشت احضر
حالي وعرفت انه لازم اوصل قبل بوقت واكون
لابسه فورمل زي هيك والاهم اني اقرا عن
اسم الوظيفه واسم الشركه والشخص اللي بده
يقابلني اكون عارفه اسمه وفعلا رحت على
المقابله
وانبسطوا مني
واكتشفت ان الشخص لما بيشتغل بشركه كبيره
ما بيكون لهم مسموح يتعرف على باقي
الاقسام شو بتعمل بيكون مركز على جزء محدد
من شغله
مش بس هيك ما كان مسموح لاني ادخل الباقي
الاقسام شو راح تعمل هون صرت احب حياه
الاعمال وصرت احب البزنس اكثر وصرت اقرا
عن الرياضيات والشركات الصغيره
اكثر بكثير من الشركه الكبيره بس اكيد راح
يدفعولي اقل
وبتشركه الصغيره راح افهم البزنس كامله
فهون قلت بالبنك ما راح يسمحولي اتدخل بكل
شيء ولا راح يكون لالي رايي بكل قسم وباي
شيء ما بخصني فقط
قعدت فتره كثير منيحه وانا بدور على الشغل
يلي بناسبني وفعلا بعد سنه اشتغلت بشركه
لسه عم تتاسف وشاركت بكل التفاصيل و
بالوقت اللي كنت بعرف جزء صغير من عمليه
كبيره صرت انا الي بحرك قسم بتكون مني انا
وشخص ولانو عندي حب المعرفه والاستطلاع
ضليتني اضحك واتعلم لحتى صارت هالشركه
الصغيره هي مشروع العلامه الكامله بالنسبه
لك صراحه ما تخيلت بيوم من ايام حياتي ان
الشيء اللي ما كنت اهتم فيه ولا اعتبره
شيء اساسي يصير محور حياتي وبالوقت اللي
ما كنت احضر فيه الورشات ولا الدورات صرت
انا الي هالوررشات وهالدورات واحمس الشباب
واحكي لهم شو المهارات اللي لازم تكون
عندي بالسوق العمل حتى اتميز عن غيري حتى
لو كنت انا اللي بجيب العلامه الكامله ومن
هذه المهارات اتعلم كيف قادر ابحث عن
المعلومه ويكون عندي على التعلم الذاتي
وتذكروا انه 85% من نجاحك في العمل بيعتمد
على مهارتك في التواصل وتوصيل المعلومه
اكثر من مهارتك التقنيه نتعلم كيف نتعامل
ونحل المشاكل ونواجهها
يا جماعه ما كنا نعرف انه احنا ممكن نشتغل
ونلاقي شغل مش بنفس المكان اللي احنا
عايشين فيه انا ممكن اشتغل
ببلدي وبيتي وبي غرفتي وبشركه عالميه تبعد
عني ايام
وهون
هاي ميس العسل الي نحن عايشين فيه بنقدر
نبعث السي في لاعظم شركه عالميه بدون ما
نتحرك من مكانه طيب شو بنحتاج لغه
انجليزيه
وقدره على التواصل
بعرف انه اهم قرار بحياتنا بيكون عمرنا 18
سنه
تكونوا عارفين انه ربع سكان العالم
بتخرجوا وما بشتغل بشهاداتهم طب هون شو
المطلوب مني انا لازم اخذ الخطبه واطور من
حالي
عن سوق العمل
ببلش من اول يوم
افتح مواقع التوظيف المواقع الاعمال
المتخصصه
مواقع التوظيف الثانيه ادور شو السوق عم
بطلب شو المهارات المطلوبه شو العرض شو
الطلب شو لازم انا اعمل
احاول احصل على تدريب او خبره ممكن
تساعدني في المجال اللي راح اخذه بعد ما
اتخرج وهنا الي اهم اني اعرف انا شو بدي
اعرف مهاراتي اعرف نقاط قوتي وقدراتي
في دراسه عم بتقول ان العديد من الوظائف
بعد خمس سنين الموجوده حاليا ما راح
نلاقيها بس صدقوني ان المهارات اللي
بيطلبها سوق العمل زي مهاره التواصل
واداره الوقت ما راح تتغير فخلونا نشتغل
على مهاراتنا ونطور من حالنا وتذكروا انه
التميز مش علامه والنجاح مش محطه والفشل
مش نهايه كل ما نحتاجه هو الامل ولا عمل
انا ايه عليان الشريك المؤسس في شركه
كلمنتينا ومديره التنظيف شكرا
[تصفيق]